جنرال
لطيف للغاية بلقائك العميد
ألكسندر تارنوفسكي هو المسؤول عما
يمكن القول إنه الجزء الأكثر أهمية في
الهجوم المضاد الأوكراني الذي يحاول
اختراق الدفاعات الروسية في
جنوب أوكرانيا وتقسيم القوات الروسية،
وقد أخبر شبكة CNN حصريًا أن لديه قوة
جديدة قوية.  السلاح الذخائر العنقودية الأمريكية
هل استخدمتها بالفعل وإلى
أي مدى تعتقد أنها
ستغير المعركة التي
حصلنا عليها للتو، لم نستخدمها بعد، كما يقول،
لكنها يمكن أن
تغير ساحة المعركة بشكل جذري، ويدرك العدو أيضًا
أنه من خلال الحصول عليها  هذه
الذخيرة ستكون لدينا ميزة. هناك
حاجة إلى تغييرات جذرية حيث أن
الهجوم المضاد لأوكرانيا لم يحقق سوى
مكاسب متواضعة في منطقته المليئة بالألغام.
وقال إن الروس أعدوا بشكل مكثف
الهجوم المضاد ناجح ولكن
ليس بالقدر الذي يرغب فيه كل واحد منا.
يخبرنا أنهم أنشأوا
حقول ألغام معقدة للغاية والتي تقع الآن في
المناطق التي ستمر فيها المعدات والأفراد الأوكرانيين عبر
تارنوفسكي،
ويأمل أن يتخلى الروس عن المناطق
التي تكون فيها المجموعات أكثر فعالية،
ويقول إن الذخائر سيتم
استخدامها بشكل صارم بعيدًا عن المدنيين وفقط مع  لقد
وصلت موافقة القيادة العليا مع
انخفاض ذخيرة المدفعية ومع ورود أخبار تفيد بأن
ضربة صاروخية أوكرانية باستخدام
صاروخ كروز بريطاني قتلت النجم
الروسي الصاعد اللفتنانت جنرال
أليكس، وهو أكبر روسي قتل في
أوكرانيا حتى الآن بعيد المدى
الذخيرة التي يمكن أن تصل إلى ما هو
أبعد من خط المواجهة
يقول تارنوفسكي إن هناك حاجة ماسة إلى
ذخيرة بعيدة المدى فعالة، ويقول إن
هذه قد تكون القضية الأكثر إشكالية
اليوم، فهي مثل الملاكمة، حيث
نمسك الخصم على مسافة ذراع على
مسافات طويلة ونهزمهم
بفعالية